- I was in Lagos,
Nigeria in 2014
when I heard about
five young men
in the north of the country
who faced the death penalty
for committing gay acts.
They were in the Sharia Law
controlled part of the country.
So I went up to see them.
Fortunately by the
time I got up there,
their case had been dismissed
and they were out of prison,
but they were homeless
and they were very afraid
and meeting them was
really difficult.
Eventually I convinced
them that it was safe
and they came to my hotel
to meet me and I you know,
heard each of their stories
and that's where
I met young Buje.
So I was deeply moved by
these stories of survival
and that's when I started;
I left northern Nigeria and
started Where Love Is Illegal.
So I documented these stories
of survival of you know,
people who had
survived persecution
from around the world,
people who have
survived imprisonment
and violent attack,
and attempted murder,
and rape, people who
had been ostracized
by their family members,
who've fled their countries,
who've done all they
can to hide who they are
because they were not considered
by their community as normal.
I told the stories of
77 different people
from 16 different nationalities.
Many of the people
I'd met were afraid
to have their stories told.
This is Sally.
She's afraid to show her
face because in Syria,
the so-called Islamic State
are hunting down gay
and trans people.
They want her dead because
she identifies as a woman.
The Islamic State don't
want you to hear her story.
And this J and Q from Uganda.
They're hiding their faces
because they are
a lesbian couple
and they fear their community.
Their community doesn't want
you to hear their story.
And this is Yves from Cameroon,
and Yves is hiding
his face because
that country arrests more
gay men just for being gay
than any other country
in the continent.
Those arresting and torturing
the gay men of Cameroon
do not want you
to hear his story.
But the reason that
these people are here
on the screen behind me,
is that they want
their story heard.
And they shared it
because they hoped
that by doing so that their
situation might change
for themselves and
for people like them.
But for some of course,
a photo poses a risk.
For some if they are identified,
they could face
further persecution
or they could even be killed.
But many of them wanted
to share their stories
and I was really
desperate to tell them.
But the only way that was
going to be possible was
if it was done
on their terms.
When I met the young
men in northern Nigeria,
at the time I was Lagos, Nigeria
and I was shooting a story
for National Geographic,
and I was using a
large format camera
and a Polaroid type film.
For those who are not familiar
with a large format camera
it's a big camera (chuckles),
and it has bellows at the
front and a glass plate
and you have to put
your head under a hood
to see everything upside
down around the wrong way.
It's not an easy process
but you know I was
photographing these portraits
with this Polaroid film
and I wanted to continue
it with this work.
Initially, I thought I'd
continue with this work
because I'd you know,
it was an aesthetic decision;
I liked the look of it.
But it actually took on a,
I think an even more
important purpose.
I gave each of the people
that I photographed
the option to
destroy the picture
if they felt that it
somehow endangered them.
So and I think
that that promise,
you know to hand
over the picture
and let them take
it and destroy it,
was a real aid in
building trust.
But I didn't have
to destroy many
and that is that
because from the outset,
I adopted a new way of working.
These photographs were
going to be a collaboration.
Initially that was a you know,
it was the terms
of the agreement
was that I had to make
it, do it this way.
But,
it's a very different
way of working
because usually as photographers
we like to control every,
you know we're kind of
control freaks,
we like to control every
aspect of the shoot.
But here I was
handing over control
to the subjects themselves
and I was allowing
them to choose
what they would wear,
how they would pose,
and how they would
express themselves.
And of course,
how much of their face
they wanted to show.
I also wanted them to
tell their own stories
and in their own words,
so I asked each of them to
write their own testimony
which would accompany
their photographs,
and when we share their
testimonies on the website,
we always quote
them absolutely, directly.
And here for many of
them for the first time
they had control over
how they were seen
and how they were heard.
But of course,
handing over control meant
that there were sometimes
some unexpected results.
I'll tell you the story about
a young transgender
woman, Jessie.
She lives in a Palestinian
refugee camp in Lebanon
and her young life
has been this,
one of extreme hardship.
She's been bullied and
thrown out of school,
she has been raped
and most shockingly,
her brother and father,
in order to protect
the family honor,
have on several occasions
attempted to murder her.
Her story was this list
of horrendous abuses
and instinctively I wanted
to make a photograph
that reflected that story.
But she didn't.
So,
we start the session
and I find a corner of a
room with some nice light
and I set up my
camera on the tripod
and you know, it's
this big camera,
and I wind up the bellows and
I put the lens on the front
(audience chuckles)
and I have my,
my cassette film,
my shutter, my cape,
and I asked her to
come into the frame.
And she covers her face
below these large dark eyes
with a scarf in order
to protect her identity,
and she starts posing.
And she pushes out her buttock
and she tilts up her head,
and starts to seduce the
camera with her eyes.
And I look through the frame
and I think, this is not
photograph I planned to take.
(audience laughs)
But,
but she is beautiful
in front of the camera
and strong, and empowered,
and I had to remind myself
that you know I was having
to give over control,
I was to let her, allow
her to portray herself
as she would like.
So despite this photograph
not matching her story,
I decided to take
the pictures anyway.
And afterwards we were talking
about her story some more
and she continued to
explain the situation
with her family and you know,
she's daily at grave
risk of being murdered
by her own flesh and blood.
And you know I listened
to her and I said look,
I understand that you
identify as a woman
but given the threats
that you face,
wouldn't it just be better
to pretend to be a boy?
And she looked up at me in shock
and she said, "I
was born this way
and I will die this way."
And in that moment,
I understood.
Her gender identity is
fundamental to who she is.
I've never had my
identity challenged.
She's threatened everyday
because of how she
presents herself.
With that statement,
I understood Jessie's courage
and her strength,
and her photograph was perfect.
This is her story.
She sees herself
as a
beautiful young woman,
a sexy young woman,
and that is who she
wants you to see.
What happened to her,
is not who she is.
So I have this
belief and that is
that storytelling is fundamental
to the human experience;
it's how we communicate
with each other
and is even how we
communicate with ourselves.
But of course the
types of stories
that we tell are
really important,
and there are
stories that connect
stories that divide.
And I think, you know
I have also this belief
that you know,
to look for difference
in each other
is a natural human instinct,
and that sometimes
for some of us
in order to feel like we belong,
we sometimes also feel
this need to exclude.
So I've been trying to
tell what I'm calling
authentic personal
stories which are stories
that come just as
much from the people
I'm photographing as
they do for myself
where their point of view,
their voice, and their vision,
is included in the
construction of the picture.
So and I have this belief also
that these authentic
personal stories
have great power to
break down these barriers
that divide us; barriers
of race and religion,
and nationality, and
gender, and sexuality,
and I really hope that
they help us to see
the person and not just a label.
And it's my hope that
in seeing the person
we can see you know,
what connects us.
So I believe that we need
more stories that connect,
but this work actually
is a testament
to the destructive power of
the other kind of stories.
Divisive stories allow
the casual discrimination
of LGBT people and
divisive stories
also allow for their
rape and their torture,
and their murder.
So what happens
when all there is
is the voice of hate?
Bigotry thrives where
those discriminated
against are silenced,
where they are
disallowed the right
to tell their own stories,
and this is repeated
time and time again
throughout history, with
every human rights issue.
Where Love is Illegal is made
to interrupt the narrative
that to be LGBT is
an attack on society,
against nature, or
an insult to God.
It is made to amplify
the voices of survivors
of discrimination,
and allow them to have
their stories heard,
stories that I
believe can connect
and stories that I believe
can help us to empathize.
So I spent a year documenting
these stories of survival
and the next important
step was to make sure
that they were heard.
I wanted to reach the
widest audience possible
and I want that
audience to feel like
they could do more than
just read the story,
but they could be in
some way involved.
So, I created some
social media accounts,
then I created a website,
and I started sharing
these stories online.
But then I also
invited other people
from the LGBT community
to share their own story,
so it wasn't just
about my photographs
or the stories that I recorded,
but people from around the world
were able to use you know,
this platform that I'd created.
And we started
getting stories from
coming from all over the place;
from Italy, from Israel,
from Iran,
Venezuela, Australia,
United States, Jordan,
South Africa,
Kuwait,
South Korea,
and many many other places.
And the goal was to
create this global voice
of people who refused to
be silenced by bigotry.
Now these voices
I'm proud to say
you know have now reached
millions around the world.
So many of the people that I met
while doing this work,
spoke of how alone they felt.
How they grew up in
societies that told them
that who they are is wrong.
And in these environments
where all one hears
is the voice of intolerance,
many sadly believed it.
But as bandwidths
continue to grow
and technology spreads,
so does the voice of
these once hidden stories.
Social media,
remarkably allows
people to connect,
in some cases, feel less alone.
And in this context,
it really is
a remarkable tool
because it's allowing
people who otherwise
would struggle to be heard,
to have a platform
to have their,
to be heard.
So in the first three months
we had 100,000
followers on Instagram
and the support was
really overwhelming,
and as a National Geographic
contributing photographer,
I was able to post on
the National Geographic
Instagram site.
So you know for
this picture alone,
we had 240,000 people like it.
You know and given that
our goal was to amplify
the voices of those people
silenced by bigotry,
social media was really
giving us a helping hand.
But it wasn't just a,
you know online that we
were creating this work,
we and sorry, it wasn't
just my photographs,
it was photographs
from other people
sharing their stories too.
For as an example is CJ
who is here from the U.S.
CJ is from a Christian family.
She lives in a very
conservative area.
CJ was drugged and gang
raped by four young men.
She was semi-conscious
during the rape
and remembers one of
them telling her that
he was saving her from
burning eternally in hell.
CJ is a lesbian.
CJ told us that
you know she was,
it was very liberating
for her to share her story
but she also talked
about how she still felt
a deep level of shame.
We were flooded with
comments of love
and support for CJ,
and many people including myself
and the volunteers at
Where Love Is Illegal,
were deeply moved by her story.
Again, social media was
allowing people to connect.
But the impact is
not just online
and we've been having
this work you know,
going to traditional
media and into
exhibitions in many
different countries.
And this is just a you know,
the many different
ways and platforms
that we are able to
have these voices heard,
including things like
doing talks like this.
But as I said earlier,
raising awareness is not enough.
So,
with some volunteers,
I created this
organization Witness Change
which is a 501(c)(3)
and you know, some
volunteers came forth,
some of them are here
tonight which is very nice,
and
impact became a major driver
in the work that we do,
and we keep asking ourselves
where is the change
in what we're doing?
How are we making a difference?
And we wanted to make sure
that we were getting the
work in front of people
who could really
make a difference
and giving them avenues
to make change happen.
So, and that's what
we've been doing.
So in every country
where I worked,
I would collaborate with
a small organization,
grass roots organization,
or a couple of people
who are working with
the LGBT community,
and we thought okay if we
can help to support them,
some of them who are
very poorly resourced,
that would be
making a difference.
So we raise some money
and we supported an
organization in South Africa
who are helping LGBT refugees,
and we raised some money
and we helped an
organization in Uganda
who are tackling
homophobic attitudes,
and when the two young guys
who helped me in
northern Nigeria,
when they reached
out to me and said,
"There's four young men
who have been arrested
for committing gay acts
and they are in prison,
and we don't have bail.
We can't afford legal
representation."
So we turned to social
media and we posted this.
And within 24 hours
we raised the money
to get the bail,
and enough money to get
them legal representation.
So we got them out of prison
and their lawyers got
the charges dropped.
So,
you know Where Love Is Illegal
has not by any stretch,
changed the world
for LGBT people,
but for these four young men,
it really made a
world of difference.